[Music]
researchers have detected strange radio
signals coming from deep space
these mysterious radio waves might just
be bursts of cosmic energy from a
distant neutron star or it could be that
scientists have discovered a highly
Advanced civilization 90 light years
away from Earth
so what kind of civilization would have
the ability to send strong signals like
this
well scientists classify civilizations
on something called the kardashev scale
it's a scale that measures a
civilization's technological ability to
harness energy
while it's a hypothetical scale that
could eventually have five or more
levels most scientists only refer to the
first few
but don't be underwhelmed we're the only
civilization we know of and technically
we're still stuck on type zero
at this stage we've managed to harness
some but not all of our planet's
potential energy
we consume about 18 trillion watts of
power every year and if we wanted to
bump ourselves up to a type 1
civilization we'd need to consume over
500 times that every second
to do this we'd need to harness store
and utilize all of the energy available
to us
that includes all raw materials and
every bit of sunlight that reaches Earth
we'd also have to tame volcanoes
earthquakes and other Natural Forces
at the rate at which we're developing
now it's possible that we could be a
type 1 civilization within the next 200
years
but whatever civilization scientists may
have discovered in the far reaches of
space could already be a type 2
civilization
or higher
okay before we can even think about
pushing our civilization to type one
we've got to take care of the planet we
already have for instance the Colorado
River is seriously running low it's
drying up because we've been using too
much water and because climate change
has brought on a major drought in 1999
Two Lakes along the river were nearly
full but today well today they're barely
a quarter full the Biden Administration
has been working hard to reduce water
usage and most States involved have
supported the plan but California which
uses the most water hasn't jumped on
board and it's concerning listen
balancing water needs isn't easy
especially in fast-growing cities and in
farming regions but climate change
affects us all and it's time to step up
our water saving game and support
leaders who are ready to tackle this
crisis only then can we start planning
how to harvest all the energy our planet
has to offer
once our civilization has all of the
energy available on our home planet
under control and we graduate to it type
one on the kardashev scale
then we need to take the next step
time to crank up our energy consumption
to 10 billion times what it was before
do this we'd need to harness not just
all the solar energy that reaches Earth
we'd need all of the energy our star
generates period
if there is a type 2 civilization out
there they're probably using an
incredible system to do this a Dyson
Sphere
they build this megastructure around
their star to collect all the energy it
radiates out in every direction
they could even assemble other Dyson
spheres around the first Dyson Sphere to
guarantee that little to no energy
escapes
there's nothing simple about this
technology and that's why only Advanced
civilizations could construct something
like it for one a Dyson Sphere must be
larger than the star itself
and if these megastructures are bigger
than Stars well they should be easy to
spot right
well this could be tricky
once a civilization is finished building
the Dyson Sphere the megastructure
blocks nearly all of the visible light
from its star
a civilization this Advanced could make
its own solar system invisible
lucky for us visible light isn't the
only way to detect a star even with a
Dyson Sphere blocking its light a star
would still radiate heat and we could
detect the Star by the infrared light it
gives off
but that wouldn't be the only way we
might discover a civilization this
Advanced remember that strange radio
signal
it originated about 90 light years away
from Earth coming from the star hd164595
was this powerful radio signal created
by an alien race and intentionally
pointed toward Earth
a civilization able to pull this off
would need to be far more advanced than
our own
this type 2 civilization would be able
to utilize the raw materials on every
planet in its star system and maybe even
Beyond
they may have built Fusion reactors that
orbit their Planet fueled with gas from
other worlds with hydrogen-rich
atmospheres
and they might be mining precious metals
from rocky planets just like Earth
they could terraform other planets into
livable worlds for their populations and
they wouldn't live in fear of
civilization ending natural disasters
like asteroid impacts ice ages or global
warming because they'd have Technical
Solutions for these too
this alien civilization would be at the
stage on the kardashev scale where
they'd be able to master Interstellar
travel but if that's true there should
be no reason for them not to pop by for
a visit right
well not so fast with all the advanced
technology they might have at their
disposal these aliens could be waiting
for us to catch up
that way when our civilizations meet we
would do so as equal partners
who knows they could be so Advanced that
they're no longer a fully biological
race
they could be more like cyborgs with a
mix of robotic and organic material
this would make them capable of
incredible things that humans could only
dream of
but they wouldn't stop there
an advanced world like this would want
to go farther up the kardashev scale and
as they became a Type 3 civilization
they'd rely on something other than the
power of their own star system
they would harness the power of several
stars in their Galaxy
with this much power a civilization
would have no problem meeting its
ever-growing energy needs they'd just
hook up another star when they needed
more power
if we ever advance to this level we'd
have 100 billion stars available to
harness in the Milky Way galaxy alone
civilization like this would no doubt be
the rulers of their Galaxy and they'd
have the power to move entire star
systems merging them to harvest the
energy they need more efficiently so if
one of these civilizations existed well
you could detect them by observing the
sudden disappearance of many stars in a
Faraway Galaxy
this could be a sign that Dyson spheres
have been constructed around not just
one but several Stars
a Type 3 civilization could already be
out there after all scientists have
announced that they've found two
galaxies with a highly unusual amount of
infrared light this is something we
usually observe in galaxies where new
stars are being born but some unusual
and sudden spikes in infrared light
could in that we've
we first signs that civilizations many
times more advanced than us exist
maybe they're about to make contact
or maybe they already have
but that's a story
for another
what if